hey house comrades my name is welcome
again is his food house of jumpscares
oh my god this game is worse than
[ __ ] 590 Freddy I I love this game so
much and what's even better is that the
game is finished and now we're gonna
finish me off with the last 250 levels
yeah thank you
you think yeah awesome
I'll see you on the other side spooky
okay here we go
249 rooms not a big deal not a big deal
at all
I've I thought I've we'd we done some
scary [ __ ] some terrifying gym escapes
again hey Chad how are you doing
okay 240 left no big deal
oh god no big deal at all I'm not scared
do I look scared this is my scared face
no there's some okay this is my I'm
gonna make out with your face fantastic
I lost my ability ah a coffee cup
anything but that coffee cop well at
least I can run down I don't like it
good that's creepy oh god oh god I'm mr.
Jeff this is scaring me I don't like
this I don't like this one bit
alright alright alright gotta go gotta
go I gotta go get high spider a filthy
Shradha
I ain't fun as long as I don't get
chased I'll be fine
where I'll be fine we're a team remember
team bros yes bros occasionally make out
now
all right just 314 to n in fort oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god okay that's
a tall man isn't it
I don't like this no don't like I'll go
right yes
made the right choice unless get it
right no survivors
it's broken just like my podcast with a
vine seller
I love the vine sound I can hear them
coming down the highway and it had but I
don't know where and now no this is not
an exit or a resting place this is not a
specimen room I think he's just outside
the door oh my god fresh tea here okay I
better head all I wanted was some wine I
need to hide ah
man okay how do I hide okay well [ __ ] me
I don't know what I hide here wine
you read my life wine oh [ __ ] my ass out
Oh God holy [ __ ] [ __ ] what that
[ __ ] that scared the [ __ ] out of me Oh
God okay okay
okay then okay
no big deal no big deal at all okay I
think we're safe what an answer how did
we get out of here why are there paprika
they're both actually scary what the
[ __ ] you're not supposed to be scary
somehow I managed to get away but I
don't know for how long I hate him even
when I know he's not there it's like he
isn't even real but instead my own eyes
my fears met affecting themself in stock
oh god do I need to hide in there as
well it seems like it this is creepy I
don't like that oh god he's coming god
damn it we only did 60 rooms
okay but I'm not making any noise I mean
no you don't such a douchebag such an
douchebag oh he dropped us key that's an
idiot all right what do we got we got a
desk book fake book like a face book get
it
what Oh God
hello that friend I didn't ever I got in
it so hard
[Music]
okay attempt [ __ ] 5i I think I figured
it out
we got a book this looks like an empty
spot bim bada boom bada Basile of my
bitty titties right I Brad let's go down
wow this place is wonderful I love it
down here I would like to go here on
vacation made of my kids
oh my [ __ ] kiss-ass oh my god what
the [ __ ] was that sound alright Adam I'm
not gonna say to find out oh god please
don't chase me I have feelings and I
don't oh my god here's know no one hears
me I'm like a bunny run like the Z way
you really mean you really mean I spend
like [ __ ] half an hour trying to
escape you you can't if you catch me now
I will not only be scared but really
pissed off when in job love still fun oh
my god you're ruin my life s curse my
peridot mad myself just kill my [ __ ] you
hundred more hundred more can we do it
yah speak on don't say like that though
yeah damn this people yes it's getting
dark
the doors are disappearing as long as we
don't have the sperm face I hate the
[ __ ] sperm face man I think something
is chasing me but I'm not gonna bother
looking back it's a McDonough's monster
much applause oh my tits on the face Oh
God
[ __ ] nada Misha I did not order this
I did not order this ow ah no my head
bubbles oh god oh my god
[Music]
we died they're fabulous
everything's gonna be a ram gonna firm
my e-penis gonna hold it jack all right
you too slow bro you're just low
Oh God top I have feeling
yes hello hello this is hello yes ah yes
hello hello yes yes hello yes yes yes
hello hello yes yes yes hello hi hi
[Music]
I don't know if you want to look
directly to the Phantom yes hello [ __ ]
it at me [ __ ] you then what I wanted
yeah
why is - not important
paintin ha poor a partner famous painter
for this game but death [ __ ] I don't
know are you trying to play the drums -
I don't understand
I'm just gonna go yeah I'm just gonna go
I'm just gonna go just game you have
that toast I love you don't let anyone
say you're not beautiful
uh-oh 3 bar 2 bar someone farted
yeah store that's just a small step for
me but a giant step for but this is
thousand you there it is ok and I'm
clicking on it bet it hello
no no no oh
the hills are fabulous I didn't think
they were real [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm out of
here
all that work for this tiny little thing
huh does it matter what you think
doesn't matter what I really
well yeah no no I don't I don't have any
dedication left inside me and left a
long long long long time ago I really
I'm serious
a thousand more okay this is weird this
is really really weird very very very
big
good for you
7m oh my god is that my god it's got the
[ __ ] bucket on me oh my god is a boss
batter
Oh God they had is trying to touch me no
you cannot right [ __ ]
Oh God [ __ ] everywhere guys guys calm
down calm down everyone calm down
I have feelings oh god he's shooting Sun
falls Sun balls are like my least
favorite kind of thing or to diaphragm
okay okay you know what I can't see you
when you do that that's okay there's
more there's more of them now fantastic
fan-fucking-tastic Oh God cha-cha-cha
extra [ __ ]
go back to your hell but you came from
I'll tickle your titties that go tech go
tech go tech go check up but if I shoot
it back oh my god it worked
as I [ __ ] eat a dick oh look at the
time it's balls o'clock yeah that's what
I'm talking about
oh yeah oh no no no I didn't die it no
no I didn't die that [ __ ]
what what is das what damn right
what do I do that did you really think I
was going to end it was going to end
seriously yeah yeah no I thought that
like three times already
[Music]
yeah
I was [ __ ] awesome great game loved it
Kirti possibly be greatest game of all
time probably not but I really like that
another smoking awesome I think you
broke really liked it too I had a lot of
fun playing I hope you enjoyed watching
it and I will see you bros in the next
whatever the [ __ ] we did all I left
that's sweet
that's really nice alright thank you
both so much and thanks to Spooky's
House of jump-scares team stay awesome
so what's up with that I don't know what
[Music]
don't worry about me brah